Here's the truth.
I work with people all the time who
tell me incredible things and then
say, do you really think anyone
wants to hear what I have to say?
And when people say that
to me, I tell them this.
I spend a week at a yoga retreat
center teaching storytelling
to about a dozen people.
The deal I have with them is
this, you never have to speak.
If you don't want to come in like
a mushroom, sit down and learn.
No one ever does that except for
once someone did a woman, she
actually sat right next to me all
week long and never said a word.
On the last day of our class, a Sunday
morning, people are going around
and sharing stories, and my mushroom
to my right finally makes a sound.
She says, well.
I have something, I just don't know
if anyone would want to hear it.
And I said, well, tell it
to us and we will decide.
So this is the story she tells us.
She said she was doing yoga one night
till about seven o'clock, and then she
got in her car and for the first time
in a long time, she had felt peace.
She had finally sort of let go of the
anger and resentment inside her and she
was feeling good as she was driving home.
And then this car came
barreling up behind her.
Her like tailgating, her weaving all
over the road, and then all of that
time she spent finding centeredness
and peace in that yoga class.
It was gone instantly.
She was angry at the person behind
her, and then that person flew around
her, went ahead and hit a pole,
wrapped the car around a telephone
pole, so she pulled over, she got out
of the car and she ran over and she
found the driver behind the wheel.
Very badly injured.
So she called 9 1 1.
Now she was up in the Berkshires
in Massachusetts, sort of
in the middle of nowhere.
And so the 9 1 1 operator said,
I need you to begin administering
first aid 'cause the ambulance is
gonna take a while to get there.
So listening to the 9 1 1
operator, she began working
on this man behind the wheel.
Eventually the ambulance arrives and
they take over, but the ambulance
driver says, I need you to follow
me to the hospital because you were
with him for the first 10 minutes.
The doctors might wanna talk to you.
She's annoyed about the whole
thing, but she agrees to go.
So she follows the ambulance at the
hospital and she takes her place in the
waiting room to see if the doctors need
to talk to her while she's waiting.
In the waiting room, a woman
walks in, her best friend, she
says, what are you doing here?
And her best friend says, my
husband was just in a car accident.
He put his car into a telephone pole.
The woman had never met her
best friend's husband before.
They had never encountered each other
because the husband worked the night shift
and so they had never seen each other.
The husband dies.
That man who she treated died shortly
thereafter, and her best friend
says to her, I'm so glad that in
my husband's final moments on this
earth, he was with someone I loved.
She tells us that story in that
workshop, my mushroom, who doesn't
speak all week, and then she says to us.
Do you really think that's a
story anyone would want to hear?
At that point, we're all crying and
I can't imagine what it takes or
what might have happened to this
woman to think that that story
doesn't want to be heard by everyone.
And yet, here's the truth.
I work with people all the time who
tell me incredible things and then
say, do you really think anyone
wants to hear what I have to say?
And what I always tell people is this,
if it means something to you, it will
mean something to other people too.
I think the tragedy of this world
is that many of us walk through the
world thinking that the moments of our
lives are meaningful only to us when
the world needs to hear your stories.
The world needed to hear that woman's
story, and yet she sat there for a week
wondering if anyone wanted to hear it.
I don't want that to be the case for you.
If you have something in
your heart and your mind.
That means something to you that touches
your heart and mind in a meaningful way.
I promise you other people
want to hear it too.
They'll even wanna hear
it if you tell it poorly.
The right story told poorly is
still a great story to tell.
So ask yourself, does
it mean something to me?
And if it does, I promise you it
will mean something to others too.